et les opérateurs peuvent t'ils
conserver les données téléphoniques
internet de leurs utilisateurs le
conseil d'état doit étudier cette
question aujourd'hui plusieurs
associations demandent à la plus haute
juridiction administrative de retirer le
décret obligeant les opérateurs à
conserver ces données de communication
pendant une année
cela relève de la surveillance de masse
selon elle et la cour de justice de
l'union européenne va dans leur sens
mais pour les autorités françaises de la
conservation des données est nécessaire
en cas d' enquête judiciaire on en a
parlé tout à l'heure avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire
les décrets en l'occurrence c'est à dire
vise à demander aux opérateurs de
conserver les métadonnées et à donner
c'est en l'occurrence les horaires
l'identité des personnes qui
communiquent entre elles sans néanmoins
conservé le contenu des conversations
donc on voit quand même que les décret
ont de par eux mêmes disent ont réduit
leur champ d'intervention
mais il est clair que dans un contexte
qui est le contexte que l'on connaît en
france et en europe plus largement c'est
à dire d'une menace terroriste qui pèse
encore fortement sur les sociétés
européennes et notamment on l'a vu sur
la société française ces dernières
années pour que l'on puisse disons
quelque part réussir à maintenir des
enquêtes qui soient efficaces il faut
pouvoir disposer en tout cas c'est le
point de vue de l'état français de
l'accès à ces données qui sont
absolument essentiels pour la bonne
conduite des enquêtes